i'm gonna have to talk to the next  person but like the audacity these  people come and i'm like i should you  should pay me to argue with you that's  how i feel about it  and i'm like they come up to me and they  have the audacity of telling me what i  need to talk about on my show  yeah go make your own show  that's what i've been saying on tick  tock they get mad at me for speaking on  my own platform i'm like if you are that  upset about it all you gotta do is  scroll up that's all you gotta do right  or just walk away from the conversation  but no they want to literally like they  get so upset and they're the ones that  are making them upset you didn't do  anything they're getting all up in arms  because god forbid you have a different  opinion than them